[تصفيق]
فيديو
[موسيقى]
انقلاب عسك
ري حولت لمسرح يتبارى
من السيطره على الحكم يذوب في لحظات قليله
ولايه جديده سيذكرها التاريخ في اقل من
ساعه واحده افريقيا تشهد رابعا سياسيا
يرعب الغرب الدب الروسي يخدع العالم كله
ويذهب الى حيث لا يتوقع احد وكل ما صنعه
احفاد لواس في قرنين من الزمان ينهار في
شهر واحد بوتين يعلنها لا علاقه لنا بهذا
الانقلاب والديك الفرنسي يصيح في الم الدب
الروسي يرتدي ثوب الحمل الوديع وكما يقول
المصريون بوتين فرنسا من المغرب
ومفاجاه من العيار الثقيل تنتظر ماكرون ما
هي قصه الانقلاب العسكري الذي حدث في
الغابون وكيف لم يهنئ الرئيس بولايه حكم
جديده لاكثر من لحظات معدوده وما علاقه
هذا الانقلاب بنفذ فرنسا واملها الاخير في
افريقيا وهل الدب الروسي يدون في كل هذا
ام ان الصفعه جاءت مره من حيث لا يتوقع
مكروه وما هي الصفقه الغربيه التي ابررتها
امريكا مع الغابون قبل الانقلاب بايام
قليله لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه ساعه الصفر صباح الاربعاء
الثلاثون من اغسطس الجالي لجنه الانتخابات
تعلن فوز مرشح الرئاسه الجابوني علي بونجو
اون ديمبا بفتره رئاسيه جديده وحصوله على
64% من الاصوات لتمتد سيطره عائله بونجو
لتمتد سيطره عائله بانجو على مقاليد الحكم
في الغابون لاكثر من 53 عاما لكن لم يهنئ
حلف باريس الوثيق وزوجته الفرنسيه بتلك
النتيجه لاكثر من لحظات كانت كافيه لان
يرفع بونجو يده يحيي الجماهير ففور اعلان
النتيجه تم سماع ذوي اطلاق نيران كثيف في
العاصمه لبروفيل
في الرئيس علي بانجو وسط الاحداث ويظهر
عشرات الجنود بالزي العسكري الرسمي على
شاشات التلفاز الحكومي معلنين الغاء نتيجه
الانتخابات وازاحه علي بانجو من السلطه
ووضعه وعائلته تحت الاقامه الجبريه
واعتقال عدد كبير من اعضاء الحكومه
والشخصيات البارزه من بينهم احد ابناء علي
بنجو نفسه وسط احتفالات وتهليلات من الشعب
الجابوني لتختفي عائله بانجو من المشهد
السياسي بعد سيطره على الحكم دامت لاكثر
من نصف قرن من الزمان لم يكتفق قاده
الانقلاب بذلك بل اعلن محاكمه رموز نظام
عديده منها الخيانه العظمى واختلاس اموال
عامه والفساد وتزوير توقيع رئيس الجمهوريه
والاتجار في المخدرات اي ان حكام الجابون
وسادتها بالامس هم اليوم على مرمى رصاص
الاعداء الديك الفرنسي يصيح
مثيرا للشفقه ولا نريد ان نقول مثيرا
للسخريه ايضا ففي اقل من شهر خسرت باريس
اهم معاقلها في افريقيا فمن بحر
اليورانيوم ونقصده هنا النيجر وازاحه
رئيسها من على راس السلطه الى ازاحه عائله
بونغو المواليه لفرنسا وحكام الغابون ملوك
الذهب الاسود في افريقيا الذي كان يغذي
احشاء الات دلوعه اوروبا وليس النفط فقط
ما تمتاز به الغابون بل ايضا الغاز
الطبيعي والمنجنيز وغيرها من الثروات
الطبيعيه والكنوز الهائله التي كانت تدخل
معظمها في معده باريس بينما يعاني اكثر من
40% من الشعب الجابوني من الفقر المتقع
والجوع والبطاله والكل يعرف الى من توجهت
اصابع الاتهام في مصيبه احفاد الوسيل
الجديده نعم يا عزيزي انه الدب الروسي
الذي اصبح لسان حاله يقول سنجعل من الديك
الفرنسيه العملاق وجبه شهيه في حفله شواء
ورغم الخلاف القائم حاليا بين بوتين
ومجموعه فاجنان الا ان موسكو كانت هي
الاسم الاكثر ترديدا في العاصمه الجابونيه
لبروفيل حتى عندما علق بوتين نفسه على
انقلاب الجابونج قائلا نرفض انقلاب
الجابون العسكري وندعو كل الاطراف الى حل
الخلافه بالحوار صاح الديك الفرنسي لا
تصدقوه هو من يقف وراء كل هذا الدب الروسي
يرتدي ثوب الحمل الوديع الرئيس يستغيث في
وسط تلك الاحداث يقطع الرئيس المعتقل علي
بانجو المشهد ويستنجد بحلفائه من الغرب من
اجل التدخل واعادته الى السلطه فقد ظهر في
فيديو قائلا انا علي بانجو اون ديمبا رئيس
الجابون اوجه رساله الى جميع اصدقائنا في
كل انحاء العالم لاطلب منهم ان يرفعوا
اصواتهم بشان الاشخاص الذين
وعائلتي ابني في مكان وزوجتي في مكان اخر
وانا في منزلي ولا يحدث شيء لا اعرف ما
الذي يحدث اطلب منكم رفع اصواتكم ارفع
صوتك اكثر يا بونجو واستنجد بمن تريد يبدو
ان لا احد يسمع كلماتك فان كانت فرنسا
ستنجدك لا انقذت من سبقك الى نفس المصير
منذ شهر واحد ونقصد هنا اهم محالف للغرب
في افريقيا ولكن مهلا يا بونغو ومهلا يا
مكروه فهناك مفاجاه من العيار الثقيل
تنتظركما هذه المره فما هي يا ترى حرب
الخيانات يبدو ان العم سام سيكون ضمن
معازيم بوتين على وليمه الديك الفرنسيه
العملاق بايام قليله اصدرت الخارجيه
الامريكيه بيانا مقتضبا حثت فيه شعب
الجابو على التمسك بحقوقه في التصويت وجعل
اصواتهم مسموعه وجاء في البيان الامريكي
كل الجابونيين يستح قون فرصه تحديد
مستقبلهم دون خوف او اضطهاد او تهديد من
احد ولا بد من مراقبه انتخابات الرئاسه
للتاكد من نزاهتها يا رباه ماذا يحدث
واشنطن تحرض الشعب الجابوني وهي تعلم
تماما ان اغلبهم يؤيدون حكم عائله بونجو
لبلادهم منذ متى والعام سام يريد مصلحه
افريقيا انها صفعه امريكيه على وجه باريس
ورغم ان لوشنطن صالح الكبرى في الغابون
فالامر لا يخلو من انتقام العم سام من
احفاد لويس بعد ان عرضوا على السعوديه
مساعدتها في انشاء مفعل نووي ضد رغبه
امريكا وقبلها خيانه العم سام نفسه
لماكرون عندما قام بتعيين سفيره امريكيه
بعد الانقلاب على بازو وكانه يعترف بشرعيه
الانقلاب الذي كان مصيبه كبرى بالنسبه
لباريس انها معركه الخيانات بين الغرب
وانفسهم وقد تظن يا عزيزي ان واشنطن بعيده
عما حدث في الغابون خصوصا وان بيان
خارجيتها يبدو دبلوماسيا في ظاهره الى حد
بعيد ولكن ماذا لو علمت ان في ابريل
الماضي قامت امريكا بتدريبات عسكريه
مشتركه مع القوات المسلحه الجابونيه
وتجهيزها لمواجهه اي شان داخليا طارق بل
هناك ما هو اغرب ففي منتصف اغسطس الجاري
قامت الجافا وامريكا بعقد صفقه هي الاولى
من نوعها في افريقيا تقتضي الصفقه بان
تعيد الغابون شراء ما يعادل 500 مليون
دولار من ديونها الدوليه على ان يستبدل
هذا الدين بقروض ارخص وبفائده اقل او ما
يطلق عليها اسم السندات الزرقاء بشرط
استثمار المبلغ في حمايه الطبيعه والثروات
الهائله الجابونيه وهي المصلحه الكبرى
لوشنطن في الدوله الافريقيه العائمه على
بحر الثروات والكنوز الطبيعيه كل هذا تم
قبل انتخابات الرئاسه الجابونيه بايام
قليله فهل من صدفه السؤال الاهم لكم
مشاهدينا هل كانت واشنطن خفيه وراء هذا
الانقلاب وهل ستتحول الجابو من سيطره
احفاد لواس الى سيطره العمي سام ام ان
الدب الروسيه سيخطف اللقمه من فم الاسود
كعاهدته اخبرونا في صندوق التع ليقات
[موسيقى]